brussels the heart of the european union
filled with protesters while organizers
had predicted around 20 000 would take
part police say at least 50 000 turned
up
we see the effects of climate change are
already among us
not only in the south of the world but
also in europe we've seen terrible
floods in belgium and in germany and
many many people
have got the effects and and are seeing
now what what the effects of climate
change are last july days of torrential
rain caused severe flooding in western
parts of europe including in belgium
where dozens of people died the
government was criticized for its late
response
this is the message from brussels to
glasgow coming from children from
families from climate activists they say
the time for talking
is gone now we need some action the eu
recently increased its climate ambitions
aiming to cut emissions by 55 by 2030
instead of 40 percent but protesters say
setting goals is one thing implementing
them is another we've already achieved a
lot all these protests at european level
they led to the european green nail they
led to quite a lot of ambition amping up
the 2030 emissions target for example
which was a really big deal something
that we've been working with for for
years and this is where we come out on
the streets and especially tell our
belgian leaders who are not as ambitious
you need to get back to work
i came as a student because it's
important to have our voices heard and
if we're given the possibility to
express ourselves we need to take it
among the crowds an activist from the
amazon in brazil
i am so thrilled to be here with these
people but they are giving
their voice
probably saying what they want for their
future generation what is very important
to me my concern is about the seven
following generations what we are going
to leave for them so that's why i'm here
just giving a little bit of
noise from the amazon
with less than a month to go until world
leaders gather in glasgow for the un's
cop 26 summit climate activists are
calling for more protests in the weeks
to come step faster al jazeera in
brussels